the lady's not for turning a hundred
years of women making their mark in
Parliament and shaping our legal
landscape from the first sitting female
MP to the arrival of a hundred and one
female Labour MPs in 1997 women have
been representing constituents up and
down the country and it all started with
this act it's called the parliaments
qualification of Women Act making it
possible for a woman to be elected to
Parliament this act allowed women to
stand to become members of parliament
without any caveats you just had to be
age 21 the same age as men there were no
property qualifications and I think it's
amazing that Parliament was willing to
pass such a radical equality Act and
really quite a short amount of time 100
years ago just a month after the Act was
passed seventeen pioneering women stood
for election Constance mark which was
the only one elected but as a member of
Shin Fane she never took her seat a year
later lady astor won a by-election and
became the first sitting female MP in
the last hundred years nearly 5000 MPs
have been elected to Parliament
but all of those just 491 have been
women so on this historic day
members of parliament male and female
are campaigning for more women to get
into politics I was a prosecutor for
many years
yes Ming Qureshi was the first Muslim
woman elected to Parliament she's part
of the campaign group fifty-fifty
parliament who inviting hundreds of
women to Westminster today to show that
they can have a place in politics I was
raised in a council housing estate I
went to comprehensive school quite far
as a barrister so I come from very
ordinary working-class background and I
hope that other people looking at
everything yes I can do so as well and
get involved in politics and obviously
become members of parliament so what is
the future face of Westminster Anna
Walker was chief executive at a Scottish
crafts company she's among those heading
to London today and hopes one day to
stand as an MP I told my career's
advisor that I wanted to be a politician
when I left school and she told me that
that wasn't for girls like me it took a
long time for me to realise that that
actually wasn't the case that was bad
advice
being a CEO seeing women and positions
of power working alongside politicians
working alongside Scottish government in
DC start to ignite something inside of
me that made me realize that that wasn't
true so after a hundred years of women
in Parliament the hope today that the
pioneers of our past will inspire future
political prodigies alie Fortescue Sky
News